[Music]
hey what's up youtube how's everybody
doing
so today i have a really cool video that
i want to show you guys
so right here we have a key for a 2013
through 2015
nissan altima and what i want to show
you guys today
is how to go ahead and create one of
these universal
prox keys by x-force using your keto max
so the first thing you want to do is
make sure you put a battery in here
okay you can tell that the battery is in
here but
there's a little light's gonna be
flashing
[Music]
so we're gonna go ahead to vehicle
remote from the main menu
actually first let's go ahead and read
this chip
okay go ahead and read the transponder
[Music]
so as you guys can see it says pcf79384a
okay so we're going to go ahead
and generate it to the nissan
altima smart key or peroxi
[Music]
okay
go ahead
these songs right here so we're gonna go
ahead
and we're gonna go to our remote we're
gonna go to ultima
and then the one that we actually won is
2013 2015
key let's go okay it looks like this
this is a generic aftermarket as you
guys can see it doesn't have a logo
but this is a regular design and this is
a new design okay
so we're gonna go ahead and we're gonna
select 2013 through 2015.
let's go it tells you that you shouldn't
have a battery
to remove the battery but that doesn't
apply to this
okay if you don't have a battery in here
it's not going to read it so you need a
battery in here so don't pay attention
to this
so make sure you have a battery in here
and we're going to go ahead and press
generate remote
right now what the key2 max is doing is
detecting it
this might take from three to four or
five minutes
for it to finish generating okay
quick little shout out if you guys want
to get um sweet deals
on keys or need any type of inventory go
ahead and hit up my voice
at uhs hardware okay
locksmith supplier that's a number
that's a website check them out you guys
so as you guys can see it generated once
now it's generating again
okay so it's not done
generating the key fully
now the thing i like about this
universal keys
is that you can have one or two of these
and then generate it
with whatever vehicle list them ketomax
gives you
if the vehicle is not on here if the
vehicle is not on here
chances are that the keto max cannot
program it or generate the remote
okay so if it's not on here it cannot do
it
so whatever keys are right here is the
key that it's gonna let you generate
if you guys have any questions email me
right now we're waiting on this remote
this one also has a slot up here where
you can put the emergency
emergency blade like this one so after
it's done generating this little light's
going to flash you guys letting you guys
know that it generated successfully
so make sure that you see a little light
flash okay you guys
okay so we're gonna go ahead and press
complete took about two or three minutes
to do that
so we're done generating it let me show
you guys a little slot where it's at
if you guys press this button
and as you guys can see has a little
slot right here for your emergency
blades
what you put right there is you put your
flip key blade
right there and then you put a little
roll pinch hold it in and
you can go ahead and and use your your
emergency
right here let me see if you have it
backwards
yep you guys can see
i hold your emergency key in there
and you guys can turn these into every
vehicle list that the mojito max gives
you
okay so these are the universal so now
we're done generating
our universal prox key we're going to go
ahead and program into the vehicle
using our key2 max and our mini obd okay
so follow me let's go do that now
all right guys so we are in the vehicle
now we're going to program the new
universal smart key there's a customer's
original key
i don't know don't ask me so i actually
ended up
connecting the keyboard supplied with
from the max kits to the mini obd
so i believe it was just lack of power i
can't think the car was getting any
power so i connected to the cable
so we're going to go to immo programming
we're going down to
nissan it should be really simple for
you guys
we're going to select nissan now we're
going to go by system okay because they
don't have the model they don't have the
the model of this vehicle in there we're
going to smart
now we're gonna go to 20 digit pin okay
you guys remember that 20 digit pin
and we're gonna go to type one okay
after 2013
we're gonna press start it's loading
we're going to go to smart key program
smart key switch ignition off turn on
double flash lights
so the double flashlight is actually the
emergency lights you guys
so we're going to press ok all keys will
be clear so you guys all the keys
are going to be erased so make sure you
have all your keys with you that want to
program
this is the customer's original key
we're going to pre-program
we're going to press yes we're clearing
all the keys you guys heard the car
beeped
that means that the keys were cleared so
keep pressing the start button until the
ignition is on so this is the tricky
part
just make sure you hold the start button
hold it don't let it go until it's on
as you guys can see you guys can let it
go now we're gonna press okay
turn off ignition switch let's go ahead
and turn it off
now we're gonna press okay press the
start button with the logo
of the first smart key so we're gonna go
ahead and we're gonna program
our universal smart key we're gonna go
ahead and press it and hold it
perfect so you guys heard it only beep
once when it beeps repeatedly that means
that it didn't accept
the key okay so we're going to go ahead
and turn it off
we're going to press it
so you guys heard it beeped like crazy
that means it didn't accept it
we're gonna use the next key
perfect so all you got to do is just
turn off the button
and you turn it on with the key okay so
you turn it off
and then you put the key right next to
and you push it with the key and hold it
right next to it it should only beep
once like i said if it be
if it beeps repeatedly that means it
didn't take the key so we're gonna press
okay
turn off ignition switch it's off please
wait for five seconds
okay my successfully key weather match
the next one we're gonna press no
because we actually really
matched all the keys we're gonna we're
gonna go press okay program success
so set the program with success you guys
so we're gonna go ahead and turn the
emergency lights off
open our vehicle we're gonna grab our
new key make sure that our new key
program perfect
perfect you guys so as you guys can see
the proxy key works perfect our mosquito
is beeping so it's
telling us um don't forget our mini obd
that's in there that's why it beats like
that
okay we're gonna check the original key
make sure the original key is programmed
as well
original key is programmed as well
[Music]
this vehicle fortunately um the signal
to pick up the
perox key is broken so the way they
actually do it is um
they put it near the start button and
they push it
you guys can see the program
successfully as well
so thank you guys for watching if you
guys like this video and helped you guys
out
make sure you hit like and subscribe to
my channel for more cool videos
okay until next time you guys take care
okay guys i want to show you a
co-function you guys
so when we select our key right here and
the menu will generate our key and we go
to mod if we go to modify this button
distance
we can actually switch the buttons
around so right now i programmed this
key
and the trunk button was actually the
panic button
okay so actually the little red one
there's a trunk button
so what i did was i ended up just
switching the numbers as you guys can
see right here it says trunk
well first we got to actually read it
okay we're going to read ours our smart
care proxy
and all the information is pop out right
here as you guys can see
everything is correct now but before our
trunk was zero one
the panic button and the panic button
was zero two so all i did was
i went and i changed this to a number to
number two
as you guys can see okay change it to
we press okay then we go to the panic
one
and this one we change it to number one
as you guys can see
okay which into number one we press ok
and all we got to do is put the remote
back in here and then we press
right and it fixes the button so if your
buttons are backwards
with each other all you got to do is
switch them around okay and you guys
should be good
as you guys can see our panic button is
a red one
so that works perfectly now okay and
then we have our trunk open already
with our trunk button if you guys want
to
update the mini obd tool
we're going to go ahead we're going to
switch we're going to go ahead and
scroll to our mini obd
we're going to press update from the
bottom and then it says firmware update
make sure that you're connected to wi-fi
because you're gonna need that
and make sure that your mini obd has
power okay as you guys can see the line
is on
and we're gonna press update
let's make sure that we connect it first
through bluetooth as you guys can see
okay we're gonna press connect as you
guys can see the light is blue now
right now it's trying to match it up
with the max q2
so we can update it
[Music]
we're gonna press update continue
and it's gonna start updating okay as
you guys can see it tells you connect to
wi-fi and sharing it is good
update may take around 10 minutes
so after the update is done you can go
ahead and press continue and you should
be good okay
so this is the way you can also connect
it to a car
okay connect it to a car the car will
give it power you can do it that way too
okay
it's all up to you